fired arby's manager admits to urinating
at least twice in milkshake mix police
say
this took place in vancouver washington
okay and look at lesbian we knew this
was happening
we there's nobody who lays their head
down at night
on any decent pillow
and says
honestly to themselves that
arby's
employees are not
urinating in the
beverages
there's no if you're honest with
yourself you laid it later close your
eyes right now and ask yourself
are arby's employees
urinating in the beverages and you your
heart will tell you yeah
because that's where we are
that's where and that honestly that's
where we've always been
and the the crazy part is
this kind of goes into that moment when
when an officer is like how many beers
have you had and you always just say two
don't say you've had more than two bro
you've had more than two
you know you left your kid in the car
one day while you were at cvs you've had
more than two beers
but that's what it is like hey mr arby's
manager sir how many times have you
urinated in the what was it
milkshake mix oh damn boy
yes sir how many times have you urinated
in the milkshake mix boy
and uh oh just twos two i've only had
two sir yeah
we we know you have more boy
look i charge extra and half of these
countries and [ __ ] they pay
rich people are drinking piss man don't
if you get bring them some piss from
them in guatemala or somewhere
foreign piss they'll sip it
dude at some of these high dollar
political functions they're over there
somebody's sommeliering off that
freaking uh that nut sniffed her dog you
know what i'm saying
off that that that that penis wine baby
piss urine
so you know rich people they'll pay to
drink that [ __ ] that's the craziest
thing you go piss on a rich person they
get mad
but you piss in a jar and put it on a
fancy website and they'll buy it
that's insane isn't it
but yeah only twice in the milk there's
no way first of all how freaking good
does it have to feel
to piss into a if that thing's mixing up
in like a beautiful
and you just dousing it up
dude i remember throwing parties in
college and i would stand by the keg it
was in the kitchen in the corner i'd
stand there a couple hundred people at
the house because we did it good
at lsu at the commons baby gang gang son
we threw that [ __ ] dude
we threw somebody uh i remember i saw
this one chick belinda caught somebody
shot a potato gun right
and she was just looking for her keys
right about 70 yards away and that thing
caught her right in the neck boy
old tottenham belinda son
damn baby she never been the same bro
she always she freaking can only look
one way when she crosses the street now
bruh she freaking that thing hooked her
um but anyway i hope she's doing good
and um
what are we talking about jeremy do you
remember it
uh we're talking about rp's maybe
oh rb's i see you saying that's a rv
that's a play on lettering and i love it
yeah arby's dog if and look i worked at
a place oh yeah i i at my joint
at the party
we would fill cold beers up in a cup and
then every now and then we would do a
cup of urine pass it off across the
party
people didn't know
those people are doing well now they
have families that's god
you know and it's just
sometime life gives you a lemonade
sometime you get that little bit of uh
that piss at the arby's
and you knew that you knew you knew when
you walked in arby's there could be
pissing some
now that you definitely knew
you knew when you walked in the arby's
something i'm eating here probably gets
a little bit of that uh
that body licker in it you know what i'm
saying
that freaking scrotum gin baby you don't
talk about piss
and one more thing about arby's is why
don't we have they need to put birth
control in the meat
why don't we that needs to be the next
thing that seemed like a perfect part of
the biden administration's uh
you know insurance medical deal
let's get birth control put into the
meat at arby's
i mean how many people would vote for
that everybody
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two
options watch one this one or this one